little box on the hillside little boxes
made of kiki tacky little boxes on the
design and they all look just the same
[Music]
you want to control your life but life
is it a science experiment you can't
contain your world forever try doing one
thing that scares you over break okay
yeah this serves as an entry voucher for
me most escape rooms immersive room yet
and win a million dollars so uh when
does the game start I think this is the
escape room we should look for clues
what are we looking for here anything
that looks like a puzzle or code it
looks like an oven dial
well that's creepy as hell is it getting
hotter how do we get out of here it's
turning 4:15 morning
talk about immersive what's wrong with
you that was a real Wow dumb question
are we outside sooner get this figured
out soon we get the hell out of here
little box watching us they know
everyone's on relief everything about us
this is my hospital bed me too they made
these rooms fronts I've never seen
things that weren't there before
that's why they chose us and they all
look
[Music]
hi in German tongue long okay sir
ditched energy the new tv-center Shawn
don't piss off quit
[Music]
there's one thing I know about the world
it's not the little things that matter
it's the tiny things do you want cheese
yes yes Jesus my life
[Music]
my name is Bella and this is how I met
Lucas see those seem to really like you
maybe that's a sign her home supposed to
be played don't use shoes oh uh don't
you shoot that one was his favorite over
the years we did everything together
good we chased a squirrel
[Music]
we went to work we even played a game
called doctor doctor doctor game
everything all right
life with Lucas was the best but when he
wasn't around I missed him so much
that's Worrell again squirrel squirrel
[Music]
duh looks like she needs help I'll wear
the chain I was very far from home but I
knew Lukas was waiting for me and I had
to go and find him
when I'm wise
even better than a tiny piece of cheese
we all face things that are hard the
only thing that gets us through it are
the special people in our lives and I
was never going to stop searching until
I found mine
[Music]
that dog saved his life
[Music]
No
[Music]
higher since cardiac death seven hours
15 minutes with the matters
you mine forever
my life's work that's what makes us you
have kids that love you and a wife that
you don't see
[Music]
and we have signed I am this close
never has anyone been there now I'm
better I can never happen what's going
on
[Music]
William
tell me the truth there was a crash
even the kids died I brought you back
there is a reason human cloning is bad
I'm
what if something horrible goes wrong
something already has
the experiments all done no it isn't
and I love you forever
I didn't define everything natural water
is just to lose you again
[Music]
[Music]
you need to prove you're looking for
work
I've been looking trust me three
signatures by tomorrow or you can tell
it to the judge
tell me about a time when you worked
hard to solve a problem this morning
getting up we're gonna find you someone
you like
let me be your arms and your legs I love
all right penthouse you need to wait
your turn
relax it's not a holdup just sign this
one please how would I sign it I don't
know slowly
what don't your arms work they don't you
can move your mouth as can you I need
assistance misses a peg hell yeah man
you are not qualified for this position
[Music]
have you change your catheter not
pinched the head insert me I can't feel
it oh well I can't you wanna feed your
soul you listen to it school thank thank
think about what you're trying to do to
me it's amazing it sounds just like ya
it's uncanny
he was Richard James II know Richard
which caused us all of these to the
right Oh God they're not practical
exactly
you can have any girl you want when box
lady logs Botox I'll be brothers forever
you can't move your body she can't move
her face they specifically said nothing
for my birthday I'm sorry you gotta have
a surprise party in a huge mansion
someone's got real problems
I'm fighting to see my son and whose
fault is it is it yours or is the world
how to get you mad I'm gonna break this
big-ass bottle of wine Dell made a mess
[Music]
this is me be relaxed
[Music]
aha CCC confer ho
[Music]
[Music]
mirar el celular del otro como Ernesto
pronto nunca jamas de faria que da da da
no secrets secrets es que tengan Zara
pues descubrimos lo Fong Yamazaki Nostra
cellular toll okay yay mensajes Yamada's
gossips la lame-o's escucha most of
those juntos
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
most basic speaker this extraneous
burner yo siento que los conozco
perfectamente no thanks for serving my
friend I was a younger man I still be
fighting 11 years my wife delivered by
c-section
maybe my son trumped everything and I'm
like you want to war no fight was always
like I never came home
which have purpose over there you have
one here to be thank you for your
service
now get off my premises is you at our
brother you gotta talk
I woke up a couple mornings ago and I
said to myself I need some excitement in
my life you ever want what I told me
that you got sick during the war she
said you had to go away she wanted to
see William that's a decision he made
when you came here your son right just
because you didn't take a bullet over
there doesn't mean the missions
[Music]
I've been this guy trying to survive is
all more stories for so long I can't
hardly remember who I'm really supposed
to be
Oh
Oh
[Music]
Elijah's changed over the years he's
given up we keep him heavily sedated but
there is a reason for that he's too
smart for them
he won't be lonely anymore we have two
new friends
[Music]
the three of you think you have
extraordinary gifts like something out
of a comic book I've developed an
effective treatment for this disorder
the light will force a different
identity to take out stuff away from the
controls so you're not gonna shake my
hand and let me walk out of here good
for you what do you want I am here to
see if tales of the extraordinary be are
true may I meet the beasts I need your
abilities to get us all out of here and
shove the world we exist that sounds
like the bad guys teaming up do you
believe you are an avenging angel
I'm within just I have to get out of
here before he gets out they are
contained
they always underestimate the master
line
it has it become David I found someone
who'll require your full attention
you shouldn't be hiding in the shadows
you might want to try and stop us
a lot of people are going to die
now who'd like a PB and J sandwich
finally all of us together for the world
to see what we are capable of you need
to get out of here
what have you done all right
wake up wake up ah if I can't
communicate with people I love what does
that mean
peace and quiet do I exist oh my god no
I'm Tilly day in two days and I live in
a shed at the bottom of moons Gator are
you okay it's got my bear on her
I want you out of that shed by a
birthday I need you to help out with the
kids company sob sin is wrong sins
da-ad up fools alive case solved
they look like Clint Eastwood really
close serious
stop following me I think of the devii
like you would I wander that's nice and
then such an angry all the time
it's next doors doors turn a little poly
clean stayin here tonight
is that your mother she finds it hard to
talk about ballet but you're doing the
same thing every day and then we'll die
you need to lighten up
she needs a man with arms she's a lot of
granite that can chuck her across the
bedroom sometimes I watch the stuff
reject something bothered
[Music]
you make out like you're the only one
who knew Billy and everybody else has to
tiptoe around you my still 24 2010 it's
one of them questions what you have to
think about
[Music]
this is for you thanks God
I make videos with my thumb's feel weird
on you I like it
are we gonna crash into the Sun probably
what is your gonna be made okay you okay
yeah
clicks mom Al and is only as good as its
leaders somebody help me hey leave him
alone
a true king is brave and noble don't be
a hero on the King around here you have
more battles yet to fight
now you must choose what you stand for
varus because he was found something
written in the guard put it into Google
Translate
it means sort of Arthur what if you're
the only person who could have pulled
that sword out
what if it's Excalibur ah finally follow
me
I am Merlin thought mine was supposed to
be in a way an ingenious disguise do you
think in four days the dark sorcerer
Morgana will take over the world just
ridiculous
there's your sore back and good luck
with everything
you're a king Alexander the sword chose
you while we help you because you're the
strongest people I know you're my
Knights and this is the round table
quick better lift up the flaps oh my god
you're such a nerd
this is this it's like an every story we
have a right Luke Skywalker Harry Potter
something amazing happens they find out
they're descended from magical families
mom don't freak out okay
this is the best and
all hail the once and future king
please don't it's embarrassing
what did you drive Mario Kart
you know how flemeth like to say
everybody knows everything it would be
fine if the truth was it nobody does
anything Alan Lebanon lemma that feels
like you've all being here forever
what is this just a little scratch
please don't kill that man know what I
will give you ten million dollars
drought my husband in the ocean for the
sharks is right and wrong heaven in hell
[Applause]
it's weird stuff going on right now this
old man's a part of it
but nobody knows it okay John you wanted
juice you don't
it's funny huh
where in the world are we
you